it started when my mom died without her
I began to fade there would get for a
good night's sleep
and disappeared from sight and from
memory
eventually you adapt I live a pretty
normal life I have a job
this girl has a sixth sense thank you I
show people as they are hey why you
following those people I'm not letting
you back in wait stay away from me
I can't you're the only person who can
who can what I'm invisible right I need
you to believe me get out of the seat
I'm the only guy in the whole world see
what am I supposed to do with that they
think we're supposed to help this one
maybe if I can fix what I broke things
will go back to normal for both of us
so you're just gonna restart my fighting
career and then you gotta get me back
with Juliana I don't think you need to
get you better than these bigger fights
how you gonna match me up with better
fighters just get me a list I have some
news
you're fighting Carlos Flores how did
you pull that off
he looks great out there I want you to
be real the shadow girl if you're trying
to make me jealous Jay what were you
doing with Giuliana she's using you
Holly wait up I care about you Hoffman
whatever he lost
[Music]
once there was a girl who was invisible
that girl is me
you